[Music]
how did finance or investing
enter the scene for you well the way i
got into finance and investing was that
i made money at blackjack and from book
royalties
and so i had this first time in my life
i had any spare money before that as an
academic my wife and i were living from
month to month with no surplus
and then kids were coming and that made
it even tougher
so
once i had some money from uh both
gambling and book royalties
i wanted to figure out what to do with
it
and so investing made good sense to me i
would put some capital aside and let it
grow
i started out by making
a lot of foolish beginner mistakes which
cost me
and then i decided to sit down and
really figure this thing out
and so i began to study
investing in my spare time so i spent
the summer of 1964
which was
i guess the third year i was at new
mexico state
just reading all summer
in a big bookstore in
beverly hills martindale's reading all
the investment books and newspapers they
had
and then i started again in the summer
of 65
reading whatever i could find and i
happened to get a little book on
warrants
common stock purchase warrants
which were the forerunner to what people
call call options now
and
when when i saw that a light came on and
i realized that i could mathematicize
this and i could figure out how to value
these things
and if i did that i'd probably be ahead
of the crowd who didn't know how to do
these things and so i'd probably have an
edge
by chance i came to uc irvine when it
opened in
the fall of 1965 and i was telling one
of the deans there
about this idea that i had and that i
was working on he said oh we have
someone else who does that
and turned out to be uh sheen cassouf
and so the two of us hooked up and she
and kasuf had actually been doing it in
practice and he'd already made
an elementary model for trying to
judge warrants
so we decided to write a book together
and work out
more of the details and theory and so
that became the book beat the market
and that launched
both of us into separate businesses
and so i began to
do what i call warrant hedges
and
basically you buy a cheap warrant and
you short common stock against it that's
one way or you buy an overpriced warrant
and
you short it up i said buy you short an
overpriced warrant and you buy the
common stock against the hedge the risk
because they tend to move together
and when
in the case of the overpriced warrant as
it collapses towards zero or toward its
uh conversion value
you capture an excess return and what i
found was that you could make a steady
25 percent a year with practically no
risk doing this
so i was doing myself
and then word spread around
uci campus and people wanted to sign up
so i signed up the dean of the graduate
division and i also signed up the
secretary to the chancellor
and some people in the math department
and so forth so i was managing a whole
collection
of
little
accounts for people and they were making
25 a year and they kept telling
everybody about it
and the dean of the graduate division
happened to be an investor also
with a fellow named warren buffett
and warren buffett was uh at that point
shutting down his partnership because
everything was overpriced back in 1968
prices were crazy
and
the dean of the graduate division wanted
to know where to move his money to
so he introduced me to warren buffett to
kind of check me out to see if i might
be a good place to put it and so warren
and i got along fine and apparently i
passed the test because the dean gave me
his money to invest
and so i got to know warren buffett
and i was sorry to see that he was going
out of business because i thought
as i told my wife then this is going to
be the richest man in the world we'll
come back to the that a little later
uh i think you'll find uh the follow-up
to that quite interesting
so when you know
i
got the idea of forming a hedge fund
from
a warren buffett who was just closing
down his hedge fund
and so i went into business
managing
accounts and then merged the accounts
into the hedge fund
and started this hedge fund or private
limited partnership
and
that ran for about 20 years and used
ideas that i kept generating
mathematical finance ideas to keep
staying ahead of other investors and
making excess returns and
in
20 years we only had three down months
out of all those months
and those down months were less less
than one percent so basically just
printed money every month
and it made just under 20 annualized
during that time
so there was a i'm very risk averse as
you you'll find as we continue to talk
and so this thing ran with extremely low
risk but yet had a very high return
so that was my entree into investing
that's one hell of an entree
you